we're going to begin with america's fast
evolving response to the newest strain
of the coronavirus it's called the
omicron variant president biden is
urging caution but he says lockdowns are
currently not we repeat not on the table
health officials warn it's likely the
strain is already here in this country
nancy cordes is at the white house with
more on the story nancy good morning to
you
good morning gail the president said
that this variant is not a cause for
panic but that it is a cause for concern
and while we still don't know exactly
how strong omicron is the cdc is already
adjusting its vaccine guidance
recommending last night that all u.s
adults get a booster
it is very likely that this virus is
already here in the united states and
circulating the cdc's new guidance says
everyone ages 18 and older should get a
booster six months after their initial
pfizer or moderna series or two months
after getting j and j
dr michael ulsterholm says the u.s could
be in for a rough winter people don't
realize we're more susceptible today in
this country as a whole because of the
number of people who are now six seven
or eight months out who have not gotten
their boosters and who are now starting
to revert back to a much higher risk and
knew overnight the ceo of moderna
reportedly said the existing vaccines
could be much less effective against
omicron telling the financial times
quote all the scientists i've talked to
are like this is not going to be good
state and local officials aren't waiting
to find out pleading with the
unvaccinated to get the shot now the
longer you wait the more risk you're
taking new york city issued new
advisories recommending a return to
masking indoors we're telling you get
those masks back on now
it's smart to do
dozens of countries including the u.s
have now imposed travel bans to and from
countries in southern africa where the
variant was first detected it's left
travelers stranded around the world
there's several thousand europeans
trying to get home via the only routes
available which is a mess for everyone
the un secretary general argued the
people of africa should not be penalized
for identifying and sharing crucial
science
president biden defended the ban we
needed time to give people an
opportunity to say get that vaccination
now before it heads it's going to move
around the world
the new omicron variant is also
threatening a rebounding economy federal
reserve chairman jerome powell is
scheduled to testify today before the
senate banking committee and according
to his prepared testimony he is going to
say that the variant poses a risk to
employment uncertainty for inflation and
that it could make the supply chain
crisis worse we know that stocks are
already taking a hit and the concern
tony is that some workers who were about
to return to the workplace may now be
reluctant to do so
yeah wait nc has become weight and worry
nancy thank you very much